foreign  I was just trying to get rid of there's  so many cameras  I didn't really even see you there what  family road trips involve a lot of  planning thankfully when it comes to  your journey  he's thinking you didn't see that coming  did you  let me try it again always be aware of  your surroundings and attentive of  approaching vehicles  I did not mean to get you in the face  yeah you did no I did it he did I need  that recording for my file we have to  slow down  [Music]  [Music]  I gotta find I think that someone do we  have HR no yeah oh here he is hello  what's your problem shut up Conan's a  great guy and then my parent this is my  favorite part that is  [Laughter]  no no there's so many witnesses  started it